اولا هذا ليس اصلاحا قضائيا هذا انقلاب
قضائه
[موسيقى]
بطبيعه الحال اسرائيل ليست ديمقراطيه
لكافه مواطنيها هي تدعي انها ديمقراطيه
للمكون اليهودي من اسرائيل اما المكون
العربي فخرج الصوره نهائيا
ما يرغب نتنياهو القيام به هو
الانقلاب على اي قرارات تصدر على السلطه
القضائيه اذا توفرت اغلبيه في الكنيست
لفعل ذلك وهذا يعني هيمنه السلطه
التشريعيه على السلطه القضائيه وبالتالي
انتفاء اي صفه للديمقراطيه
لانها غير مبنيه على مبدا رئيسي في
الديمقراطيه وهو عدم تغول اي سلطه على
الاخرى في البلاد
ايضا هناك انقسام حقيقي ليس فقط
داخل المجتمع الاسرائيلي اليهودي ولكن بين
هذا المجتمع وبين
الجاليات اليهوديه في الخارج التي كانت
تنظر دائما لاسرائيل على اساس انها دوله
ليبراليه ودوله ديمقراطيه مره اخرى للمكون
اليهودي لانها لم تكن يوما تنظر الى
المكون العربي داخل دوله اسرائيل هذه
المجتمعات ايضا لا تستطيع ان تصف اسرائيل
اليوم بانها دوله ديمقراطيه
وهذا ما دعى
اعداد كبيره من اليهود
الاسرائيليين بالتظاهر ضد حكومه نتنياهو
هناك ما
يربو عن مئه الى 150 الف متظاهر بشكل
اسبوعي لمده 23 اسبوع متتالي
وهو ما يشير حقيقه الى انقسام حقيقي داخل
اسرائيل اليوم
المشكله اليوم ان نتنياهو يرغب في فعل اي
شيء لضمان عدم دخوله الى السجن وبالتالي
هو مستعد
لمسايره
الاحزاب والاشخاص الذين يقفون اليوم على
يمينه حتى لا يدخل السجن لكن
اذا تمادى نتنياهو في
هذا الموقف
سيؤدي ذلك برايي الى مواجهه حقيقيه
ليست فقط داخل اسرائيل ولكن مع الجاليات
اليهوديه خارج اسرائيل وبالاخص الجاليه
اليهوديه الامريكيه التي بدات تتمل
بالفعل من هذه التصرفات قد لا ينتج عن ذلك
يعني
تحول علني وسريع في موقف هذه الجاليات من
اسرائيل لانه بطبيعه الحال هذه الجاريات
يعني تتردد كثيرا قبل ان تاخذ اي موقف
ينتقد حكومه الحكومه الاسرائيليه لكن مع
مرور الوقت واذا استمرت هذه التصرفات واذا
اصر نتنياهو على موقفه لانه لديه الغالبيه
في الكنيست لفعل ذلك اذا اسر على هذا
الموقف سينتج عن ذلك براي انقسام بين
الجاليات اليهوديه خارج اسرائيل وبين
اليهود الاسرائيلي
[موسيقى]
اداره الرئيس جو بايدن تحاول بكل الاشكال
تجنب خلافات مع
الحكومه الاسرائيليه هي لديها انتخابات
رئاسيه في العام القادم ولا تريد اي مشاكل
مع الحكومه الاسرائيليه حاليا ولكن بدانا
نشهد اليوم
انتقادات علنيه لاسرائيل من اعضاء في
الكونجرس
وبشكل يعني اعداد يعني جيده
مره اخرى
لن يؤدي ذلك الى تغير في موقف الكونجرس
بشكل عام من اسرائيل في الاونه يعني في
الفتره الحاليه ولكن هذه الانتقادات
العلنيه التي بدانا نشهدها غير مسبوقه
هناك ما يقرب ربما من ربع اعضاء
الديمقراطيين داخل الكونغرس ممن يعني
ينتقدون اسرائيل عل نيا اليوم وبشكل غير
مسبوق